ensuite comment ça fonctionne et donc le
présent amendement vise à ce que pour
déterminer la location qui convienne le
mieux à l'épargnant le gestionnaire
prenne aussi en compte ses préférences
aux manières de durabilité selon des
modalités proches de celles qui sont
prévues à l'article 17
quelle est la vie du gouvernement sur
cette amendement de Navarre mais ma vie
à vie de sagesse
je
consulte l'assemblée on a une demande de
soutien public que sur celui-ci madame
briquet faites-nous une petite
explication de votre ça va nous aider
merci de la même façon précédemment ça
va plutôt dans le sens du renforcement
de la protection des épargnants donc on
y met un effet favorable
[Musique]
en suivra d'accord donc je mets aux voix
qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté
on passe à l'article 16 à l'article 16
la parole est à vous madame briquet
merci madame la Présidente je tiens au
préalable à saluer les efforts de
réécriture de Madame la rapporteur des
articles du titre 3 et singulièrement de
cet article 16 néanmoins c'est
réécriture ne change pas l'économie
générale du texte et du financement du
verdissement de l'industrie ainsi la
mesure phare de ce texte à savoir le
plan épargne à venir climat à
destination des mineurs avec un
financement espéré à hauteur d'un
milliard relève davantage de la
communication que de l'efficacité outre
le fait que ce nouveau produit d'épargne
ne réponde pas aux enjeux en matière de
transition écologique et rendent encore
plus visible le manque de financement
public les contours de ce dispositif
sont assez floues les précisions sur son
champ d'application est en renvoyé à un
futur arrêté ministériel par ailleurs le
lancement de ce livret interroge quant
aux conséquences qu'il pourrait avoir
sur les produits existants comme comme
par exemple sur le livret A et donc le
financement du logement social qui lui
est rattaché je vous remercie monsieur
broyier pour paroles merci je souhaitais
faire cette prise de parole pour évoquer
deux choses d'abord il y a une
utilité à mobiliser l'épargne populaire
en faveur de la transition écologique
non seulement une utilité mais même une
nécessité et nous croisons les uns et
les autres beaucoup de citoyens qui
aimeraient avoir la certitude lorsqu'il
souscrivent un ldds par exemple que le
placement sera réellement utilisé au
bénéfice de la transition écologique le
sujet qui va nous animer avec ce plan
avenir climat ne répond pas parfaitement
mais j'aurais l'occasion d'y revenir par
des amendements à ce sujet malgré une
amélioration notable à portée par notre
rapporteur mais je souhaitais insister
sur cette question de construire qui est
plutôt un sujet de PLF construire de
véritable outil de placement financier
vers permettant de donner une confiance
à l'ensemble de nos concitoyens en
prenant un exemple dans le ldds par
exemple vous pouvez souscrire des fonds
plutôt sociaux d'accompagnement aux
EHPAD qui vont aller nourrir une société
comme hors pa le lien entre une société
comorpa et la valeur sociale du travail
fourni bien sûr ils accueillent des des
résidents et c'est des résidents âgés
mais dans le des conditions qui font
douter de la réelle valeur sociale de
l'action hors PA et c'est exactement la
même chose au plan de la transition
écologique donc c'était cette prise de
parole pour inviter le gouvernement à
l'occasion du PLF a réellement réfléchir
avoir des livrets je l'avais déjà évoqué
à l'occasion de l'agriculture avoir des
livrets dans lesquelles les épargnants
puissent avoir une confiance absolue que
leur argent sera réellement utilisé au
bénéfice de la transition écologique ce
qui n'est hélas pas le cas aujourd'hui
et ce qui ne sera sans doute pas le cas
de ce plan à venir climat dont nous
allons maintenant débattre
alors nous commençons avec trois
amendements
identiques de suppression comme Monsieur
Breuillet ne vous aura assayez pas c'est
à vous
donc je l'ai un peu annoncé cet
amendement vise à supprimer cet article
16 au profit d'autres propositions
destinées à mobiliser l'épargne des
Français dans des proportions et selon
des modalités conformes aux besoins de
la transition écologique le plan épargne
à venir climat et la seule véritable
mesure innovante du volet finances de
votre projet de loi mais c'est un autre
avis une fausse bonne idée certes la
transition écologique notamment dans
l'industrie verte a besoin
d'investissement massif la mobilisation
de l'épargne des Français pour couvrir
les dizaines de milliards d'euros
nécessaires doit se faire sur une partie
des encours disponibles sur les produits
d'épargne existants et cela or les
activités les plus polluantes nous
proposons donc que cette mobilisation de
l'épargne soit fléchée sur les encours
issus de l'épargne salariale de
l'assurance vie grâce à une refonte des
règles qui s'y applique notamment en
termes de fiscalité de garantie et de
liquidité ce plan d'épargne gèle les
fonds jusqu'à 18 ans de l'enfant et ceci
nous laisse penser qu'il se destine plus
particulièrement à ceux qui moins
fragiles financièrement peuvent se le
permettre dans les familles populaires
lorsque on le peut on ouvre un livret A
qui est l'épargne rassurante des
catégories modestes le livret plan
avenir climat est au contraire un
produit financier qui comporte des
risques et qui sera nous le pensons
réservé à des catégories sociales plus
aisées notre combat en tant qu'ecologie
et de réduire les inégalités sociales
autant que les inégalités que
l'injustice climatique nous considérons
donc que ce livret pourrait les
accentuer au lieu de les combattre sans
pour autant répondre aux objectifs
d'investissement vert qu'ils poursuit ni
par le montant qu'il pourra rassembler
ni par la définition insuffisante du
caractère vert des investissements rien
ne garantit à ce stade que l'argent
épargné au nom de l'avenir climat ne
finance ou non des entreprises qui
développent de nouvelles capacités de
production ou de transport d'énergie
fossile nous proposons donc de supprimer
cet article
madame briquet
si vous voulez dire qu'il est défendu je
peux le faire madame présidente donc
défendu si Monsieur gay il défendu c'est
une petite indication à l'Assemblée nous
avons examiné 26 amendements en 1h 3/4
et il nous en reste 49 chacun tirera les
conclusions qui s'imposent
donc quelle est la vie de la Commission
alors c'est un avis défavorable tout le
monde sait ce que je pense de ce produit
il est nouveau donc moi je pense qu'il
faut lui donner sa chance d'exister il
n'empiette sur le périmètre d'aucun
autre produit qui existe actuellement
sur sur le marché donc après il sera
efficace ou pas l'avenir nous le dira
mais en l'état et vous l'avez tous dit
les travaux de la commission ont quand
même permis de l'améliorer et j'ai un
certain nombre d'amendements à vous
proposer pour poursuivre dans cette voie
à la fois sécurisé davantage ce qui
investiront dans ce produit et en même
temps s'assurer que les fonds investis
iront bien vers l'objet de ce plan
monsieur le ministre
oui je m'exprimer une seule fois sur le
sujet pour marquer mon désaccord sur
l'appréciation qui est porté sur ce
produit vous avez un enfant vous voulez
lui offrir un placement aujourd'hui vous
avez le livret A
point barre je pense que c'est pas
mauvais d'offrir une autre possibilité
comme très bien dit la rapporteur il
faut donner sa chance à ce produit ce
produit les particulièrement attractif
avec zéro fiscalité et zéro charge à la
sortie car aucun autre produit aucun
autre placement sauf le livret A qui
bénéficie d'une telle garantie c'est un
placement de long terme donc avec la
gestion pilotée qui va aller en étant de
plus en plus sécurisé au fur et à mesure
qu'on se rapprochera des 18 ans on
garantit un niveau de rémunération qui
doit être en théorie je suis prudent
Christine avant de la rappeler dans ces
questions supérieures à ce que peut être
un livret A c'est pas le même niveau de
garantie puisque la garantie du taux du
livret A elle est législative mais c'est
un niveau de garantie élevé quand vous
regardez déplacement dans le passé sur
les 20 ou 30 dernières années bah les
placements en action ont plus rapportés
à leur bénéficier et à ceux qui on fait
ce type de placement nous avons aussi la
garantie renforcée par les décisions qui
ont été prises par le Sénat que ce
placement sera intégralement et
totalement vert c'est à dire pour des
entreprises qui respectent des
obligations vertes et qui s'engagent la
transition écologique donc moi je pense
très sincèrement que c'est un beau
produit il y a en plus des conditions
qui sont fixées pour pouvoir libérer ce
produit avant terme si vous avez un
accident si vous voulez avoir une
formation je pense que tout cela est
bien conçu et que le travail qui a été
fait par la Commission a été
particulièrement efficace donc je crois
beaucoup dans l'opportunité de ce
produit de manière plus générale nous
avons un défi de financement la
transition écologique qui est
extraordinairement élevé et si nous ne
voulons pas passer par la case impôts
c'est un autre débat mais nous nous
estimons aujourd'hui que la fiscalité
est trop élevée pour passer par cette
case là il reste l'argent public on en
met déjà beaucoup
la mobilisation des investisseurs privés
c'est absolument décisif et l'épargne
des Français et la réorientation de
l'épargne des Français me paraît
absolument capital pour gagner la
bataille du climat est-ce que le produit
lui-même suffira non je vais pas vous
raconter n'importe quoi non bien sûr que
ça ne suffira pas mais c'est une
première brique dans une politique plus
globale qui doit nous amener à mobiliser
les 3000 milliards d'euros d'épargne des
Français vers la transition écologique
je pense que c'est une des sources de
financement les plus intéressantes et
les plus utiles
merci
[Musique]
ces trois amendements identiques je suis
encore saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public on fait un même vote comme
d'habitude
même vote donc ils sont rejetés le 350
madame bollygein
oui mesdames la présidente cet
amendement est un peu la première
station vers l'amélioration du
dispositif naturellement il va falloir
drainer des capitaux de façon
extrêmement massive pour assurer la
transition écologique que nous appelons
de nos vœux dans le domaine de
l'industrie en commission un amendement
de notre rapporteur a réécrit cet
article 16 en supprimant notamment
l'abondement de l'État cette suppression
avait pour mérite de limiter le coût
pour les finances publiques de la
disposition toutefois nous pensons que
l'abondement pour toute ouverture lors
de l'année de naissance présente un
double effet positif pour la transition
d'une part créer une fenêtre
d'opportunité d'un an pour encourager
les parents à recourir au plus tôt à ce
produit d'épargne maximisant ce faisant
la durée de blocage des dépôts
d'autre part inciter les foyers les plus
modestes à ouvrir un tel produit
d'épargne en leur permettant de
bénéficier d'un coup de pouce de la part
de l'État qui amplifierait cette épargne
c'est pourquoi notre amendement propose
en conséquence de rétablir l'abondement
de l'État pour toute ouverture d'un pack
au cours de l'année de naissance mais en
le conditionnant au revenu du foyer
l'idée
c'est de ne pas avoir une double
comment dire
faciliter fiscale on est au zéro charge
on est au zéro fiscalité dans un souci
un peu de moralisation du dispositif et
aussi de cette gestion des finances
publiques qui nous semble que
avoir pour référent le niveau de de
revenus du foyer est un bon compromis
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement
alors c'est un avis défavorable et en
commission je vous ai expliqué pourquoi
est-ce que dans la rédaction de
l'article 16 nous avons supprimé cet
abonnement qui finit qui figurait pardon
dans le dispositif décrit de manière
succincte dans le texte déposé par le
Gouvernement plusieurs raisons à cela
aujourd'hui seul 5% des mineurs dispose
d'un contrat d'assurance vie ce plan à
venir climat dans son fonctionnement il
correspond exactement à la même chose
qu'un contrat d'assurance vie si ce
n'est qu'il devra arrêter d'être abondé
à partir de 18 ans et clôturer à 25 ans
alors qu'un contrat d'assurance vie
ouvert à la naissance de l'enfant pourra
lui durer jusqu'à son décès c'est la
différence substantuelle entre les deux
dispositifs donc on aura un produit qui
sera désensibilisé à compter des 18 ans
et un produit suivant le profil de
risque choisi par les parents et ensuite
par l'enfant devenu majeur qui pourra
évoluer comme il le souhaite
si besoin jusqu'à son décès donc
aujourd'hui l'idée de ce plan à venir
climat c'est devenir chercher ces
pourcentages au dessus des 5%, qui ne
vont pas vers un produit un peu risqué
parce que ils ne sont pas forcément très
connaisseur en matière de finance et que
comme ce produit sera distribué
notamment par les réseaux bancaires il
sera plus accessible puisque votre
conseiller pourra vous dire ah vous
venez d'avoir un enfant est-ce que vu
votre profil vu vos revenus vous
pourriez être intéressés par ce
dispositif mais là encore on s'adresse
quand même à des foyers qui ont un
certain niveau de revenus puisque les
fonds qui seront placés sur ce plan à
venir climat sont bloqués sauf qu'à
extrême prévu par l'article 16 jusqu'à
la majorité de l'enfant à minima ou
jusqu'à 25 ans ensuite ce sont des
sommes engagées qui sont risquées même
si effectivement quand on regarde dans
la durée les placements en assurance vie
en unité de compte ou un rendement
meilleur que les placements
euros ou les placements sur livret il y
a toujours une incertitude qui demeure
donc on va venir s'adresser à des
ménages aisés ou modeste plus et donc
pour moi il y a un véritable effet
d'aubaine en fait à venir verser cet
abonnement ceux d'autant plus que si ce
produit ça va un produit concurrentiel
pour les établissements qui vont le
distribuer vous avez qu'à voir on peut
l'observer quand les établissements
veulent attirer de nouveaux clients ils
savent faire ce geste commercial en
venant ajouter quelque chose à la
souscription d'un nouveau produit donc
six produits ils répondent à ces
objectifs et notamment qui l'offre cette
rentabilité il trouvera ses clients et
les banques seront aussi ou les autres
distributeurs accompagnaient le
mouvement donc pour toutes ces raisons
et comme je partage avec vous le souci
des finances publiques je vous invite à
le retirer ou sinon ce sera défavorable
merci quelle est la vie du gouvernement
je partage le raisonnement
implacable de la rapporteur j'entends
parfaitement les arguments de la
polygagen sur l'abondement mais
je pense l'avoir fait comprendre à c'est
clairement lundi dernier nos finances
publiques doivent nous amener à être
vigilants sur le moindre euro dépensé
donc l'idée que vous avez d'avoir un
abondement même limité au départ c'est
généreuse il dit qu'il peut être
efficace effectivement parce que la
moindre incitation financière toujours
utile pour faire démarrer un projet mais
je crois très sincèrement qu'il est plus
sage aujourd'hui de laisser vivre ce
produit en sortant de la logique de
l'abondement une fois encore
l'amendement est efficace l'amendement a
du sens l'amendement serait parfait dans
une période de finance publique
généreuse et avec un budget à
l'équilibre nous en sommes loin et l'AS
donc tout en
notant l'intérêt de l'amendement ma
suggestion est un retrait sinon avis
défavorable
j'apprécie la plasticité mentale dont
fait preuve l'exécutif je vais le
retirer mais j'avoue que le back-office
de la rédaction de cet amendement je
vais méditer longuement sur ce processus
merci le 115 monsieur Kern
le président le présent amendement vit
sa garantir que les différentes
composantes de la transition écologique
dont l'élimination du carbone
atmosphérique puisse bien être financé
par le Plan d'Épargne à venir climat
c'est dans la poursuite de mes
propositions initiales nous souhaitons
que l'épargne
nous voulons clarifier l'objectif
principal de ce plan d'épargne à venir
climat et tout d'abord nous assurer que
l'ensemble des encours seront bien
fléchés vers la transition mais aussi
que l'économie productive qui est cité
ne soit pas la principale cible de ces
encours au détriment tous les cas de la
fonction transition c'est pourquoi nous
demandons que l'épargne mobilisée sur
l'économie productive le choix aussi sur
l'économie présentielle qu'elle soit
réellement utilisée pour la transition
écologique et ne finance pas des
entreprises qui se développent sur la
rente de l'énergie fossile c'est une
garantie qui est nécessaire pour la
sincérité du caractère vert de ce
placement
merci Madame briquet me l'identique
identique donc défendue madame
présidente merci nous avons le 178
monsieur buis merci président de cet
amendement vise à garantir que les
différentes composantes de la transition
écologique dans l'élimination du carbone
atmosphérique puisse bien être financé
par le Plan d'Épargne à venir climat
merci quelle est la ville de la
Commission sur ses amendements
alors je vais dire des demandes de
retrait parce qu'en fait ils vont tous
être satisfaits si vous adoptez
l'amendement 399 à venir et pour ce
notamment qui demandait des allocations
vers des produits moins risqués
notamment le 115 et le 178 leur dire que
c'est prévu en fait par le mode même de
gestion de ce plan qui dès le moment où
on approche de la liquidation c'est à
dire les 18 ans les fonds vont être
rallumés pardon vers des placements peu
risqué et liquides donc ça c'est
satisfait et pour tout le reste pour
tout ce que vous demandez l'amendement
399 y répond
monsieur le ministre
oui mais ma vie que les rapporteur de
profil intervention pour donner le point
à Madame paoliagin que les choses soient
bien claires effectivement il y a eu des
débats
notre décision s'est arrêtée finalement
sur un souci de finance publique mais je
reconnais bien volontiers que votre
remarque était parfaitement justifiée
merci alors que deviennent tous ces
amendements le 115 il est maintenu
il est rentrée le 8 et le 25 vont donc
être mis au mois
toujours une demande de scrutin public
j'imagine on fait le même vote que
d'habitude
ok donc ils ne sont pas adoptés et le 78
il est retiré voilà le 225
elle est
le 392 non plus
nous passons au 9 monsieur Breuillet
c'est le 9 pardon
excusez-moi
il s'agit dans cet amendement de
préciser les principes d'allocations au
profit de la transition écologique
pour assurer la bonne affectation de
l'épargne au profit de la transition
écologique ainsi que pour minimiser le
risque que l'épargne finance des
entreprises dont les activités iraient à
l'encontre de l'objectif affiché cet
amendement propose donc des garanties et
notamment d'exclure de l'univers
d'investissement du Plan d'Épargne à
venir climat toutes les entreprises dans
les activités économiques porteraient un
préjudice environnemental au sens du
principe d'une autre signification armes
de la taxonomie européenne cela
exclurait notamment les entreprises qui
contribuent à l'exploration la
production la transformation et le
transport d'énergie fossile charbon
pétrole au gaz la pré-oxfam en 2020 les
banques françaises ont injecté 100
milliards de dollars dans les
entreprises actives dans les énergies
fossiles c'était en hausse de 22% 2020
et elles sont les premières financieuses
européennes des énergies fossiles selon
le rapport banking en climat chaos
actuellement ce plan d'épargne ne
fournit pas les garanties nécessaires
pour assurer le bon investissement dans
les projets durables il ne suffit pas de
l'appeler avenir climat pour avoir ces
garanties et l'objet de notre amendement
et de demander des précisions qui
garantissent qu'effectivement aucun
soutien dans les énergies fossiles ne
soient possibles avec ce plan à venir
climat madame briquet
identique au précédent donc défendue
madame la Présidente merci quelle est la
vie de la Commission sur ces amendements
là aussi ces amendements pour être
retirés au profit du 399 parce qu'en
introduisant cette définition en fait on
pourra voir quelque chose de trop
restrictif dans le champ des actifs
éligibles et dans le 399 on vient
répondre justement à ce souci qu'on
partage d'avoir quand même un plan à
venir climat qui soit majoritairement
orienté vers le financement de
l'industrie verte
avait du gouvernement même à vivre
bien il y a toujours une demande de
scrutin public sur ses amendements on
fait un même vote
même votre
c'est vous qui décidez moi je suis votre
exécutante en la matière
ils ne sont pas adoptés de 399 madame
Lavarde
le fameux 399 donc juste pour vous pour
éclairer tout le monde dire que cet
amendement vise à préciser les titres
dans lequel le plan avenir climat pour
être investi donc comme beaucoup l'ont
dit en présentant leur amendement il
paraît nécessaire d'encadrer
l'allocation des versements sur ce plan
d'épargne sur ce plan pour conserver son
effet incitatif et s'assurer qu'il
réponde à nos objectifs visés à savoir
financer la transition écologique et
l'économie productive donc les titres
contribuant à la transition écologique
seront définies par référence au label
reconnu par l'État en la matière donc
notamment les labels green fine et ISR
ils devront également inclure les
obligations vertes vertes ce qui n'était
pas prévu actuellement mais ce qui va
permettre de pouvoir désensibiliser les
produits tout en gardant un côté vert au
plan au Plan Climat et donc un décret
l'histoire la liste des activités qui
elles sont complètement exclues des
allocations des versements les titres
contribuant à l'économie productive
seront définies eux par référence à un
cahier des charges qui listera notamment
la liste des entreprises et des secteurs
éligibles et enfin cet amendement
précise que la part des titres
contribuant à la transition écologique
ne devra jamais être inférieur à celle
contribuant à l'économie productive donc
je pense que ça répond à un certain
nombre de préoccupations qui ont été
exposées dans les amendements précédents
quelle est la vie du gouvernement sur
cet amendement
cela m'arrive rarement mais c'est un
avis défavorable j'ai peur qu'on
s'engage dans des règles de gestion trop
complexes et que ça tue le
projet dans le on a un produit d'épargne
qui est nouveau qui est le plus simple
possible le plus attractif possible d'un
point de vue fiscal et d'un point de vue
social je pense que si on va trop loin
dans les modalités de gestion la
définition des produits verts on a
vraiment un gros risque que la
complexité rebute l'épargne d'expérience
depuis 6 ans tout ce qui est simple
marche
tout ce qui est compliqué et chou donc
c'est aussi basique que ça c'est le
produit des pannes retraite a été un
immense succès c'est que le Parlement
dans sa grande sagesse à simplifier tous
les produits des pains de retraite pour
faire ce Peel on est arrivé à un
dispositif ultra simple il a des défauts
il y a des effets d'aubaine je l'ai mis
absolument pas mais ça marche et donc je
pense que pour ce produit d'épargne si
on veut que ça marche il faut accepter
que il y aura peut-être des
améliorations à faire au fur et à mesure
mais au départ faisons simple pour
garantir le succès du produit
merci Monsieur dessus
si on veut garantir le succès de ce
produit il faut garantir la confiance
qu'on peut avoir dans les placements et
dans l'argent qu'on qui pourrait être
placé sur ce sur ce plan et je pense que
malgré la complexité il faut quand même
des garanties que quand on mettra
quelques deniers sur ce livret il faudra
être sûr qu'on ne finance pas des
projets dangereux climaticides etc et
que à la preuve au premier accueil on va
détruire la confiance plutôt et faire
échouer ce produit et donc je pense
qu'il faut quand même voter les les
quelques garanties qu'on peut avoir dans
cet amendement
monsieur solomunotorise je vais faire un
vote à main levée
donc ça passe qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient c'est
adopté
alors le 400 madame Lavarde
oui alors cet amendement en fait vise là
cette fois-ci à assurer un peu la
protection des épargnants et notamment
par l'encadrement des frais qui seront
appliqués à ce plan avenir climat en
renvoyant à un décret en fait le niveau
du plafonnement pourquoi est-ce qu'on
fait ça c'est parce que le produit est
nouveau et la l'évaluation la dernière
qu'on connaît c'est celle qui a été
portée par le fameux comité consultatif
du secteur financier qui analysait en
fait ce qui s'est passé pour les paires
individuels et le comité constate dans
un rapport de 2021 le manque de
transparence c'est le niveau des frais
appliqués à ces titulaires de ces de ces
nouveaux pairs donc pour éviter qu'il
arrive la même chose à ce nouveau
produit et donc lui donner toutes les
chances de réussite par cet amendement
nous propose enfin nous demandons en
fait un encadrement des frais de gestion
monsieur le ministre quel est votre avis
sur cet amendement
là aussi à vie défavorable par souci de
respect de la concurrence la vie du
consommateur on a un principe de
transparence avec l'information annuelle
sur la performance et sur les prêts les
frais pardon ce tableau sera défini par
décret donc il nous semble que c'est
suffisant donc elle vit négative ou
proposition de retraite
qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
deux identiques deux amendements
communes madame paoligajen je vous
invite à présenter les deux
successivement
oui madame la Présidente le 348 rectifié
l'article 16 dont on débat prévoit qu'à
partir de la majorité du titulaire du
plan au 15 nouveaux versement n'est
possible
sur ce plan qui est clôturé lorsque le
titulaire atteint l'âge de 25 ans cette
limitation entre en contradiction avec
la nécessité de mobiliser on l'a dit des
capitaux massifs mais aussi sur le temps
long car le flux d'investissement
nécessaire la transition écologique de
notre industrie devra monter en
puissance au moins jusqu'en 2050 d'où le
présent amendement qui supprime cette
limite d'âge pour renforcer le
dispositif et le second est un
amendement de repli qui porte la durée
de 25 à 30 ans par un porteur
alors c'est un avis défavorable puisque
ce dispositif s'appelle plan avenir et
climat et en fait dans avenir il faut
aussi je pense comprendre à venir des
mineurs pour lesquels le dispositif est
souscrit et donc en fait puisqu'on le
dispositif prévoit le déblocage des
fonds à 25 ans c'est de venir les aider
soit financer leur entrée dans la vie
adulte soit à venir financer leurs
études si le produit est liquidé à 18
ans après pour tous les autres qui
voudraient placer de manière active de
l'épargne pour leurs enfants et sur une
durée beaucoup plus longue il existe
l'assurance vie parce que je le redis
aujourd'hui si vous souscrivez un
contrat d'assurance vie pour votre
enfant mineur vous faites exactement la
même chose que ce que vous allez faire
en souscrivant un plan à venir climat si
ce n'est que vous n'aurez pas
l'obligation de liquider le produit au
25 ans de l'enfant devenu majeur donc
pour toutes ces raisons c'est retrait ou
défavorable et en plus en fait le
problème c'est que si jamais
on vient allongé la durée pendant
lesquelles les fonds sont immobilisés
sur ce plan et alors qu'ils ont été
désensibilisés puisqu'à partir de l'âge
de 18 ans le produit peut être liquide
donc ça veut dire que le gestionnaire va
forcément désensibiliser va mettre sur
des produits liquides donc c'est des
produits qui sont moins orientés des
industries risquées donc c'est moi en
termes de d'utilisation optimale de
l'épargne c'est moins efficace que de se
tourner directement vers des produits
qui s'inscrivent dans une longue durée
d'investissement donc retrait ou
défavorable même avis très bien Madame
Paoli vous redire
ensuite nous avons
[Musique]
allez-y merci Madame la président de
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues il
s'agit d'un amendement préparé par notre
collègue à l'un Dufour et qui vise à ce
que les plans d'épargne climat est en
souscrit pour des mineurs que ces
mineurs puissent lorsqu'ils leurs études
de pouvoir utiliser le livret pour
financer leurs études
mais ma vie monsieur le ministre retrait
il est retiré le 278 monsieur gay
oui c'est un amendement de repli nous
nous opposons la défiscalisation et à la
désocialisation de ce nouveau produit
d'épargne
madame la rapporteur le 325 c'est le
pardon monsieur le ministre
toutes mes excuses
vous avez un amendement presque
similaire à celui de Monsieur gay
monsieur le ministre est un moment
important dans l'hémicycle
un article près
vous proposez de supprimer les 45 et 46
et Monsieur Grey ajoute le 40 positions
monsieur le ministre je suis désolé je
n'ai pas entendu ce que vous avez dit
nous proposons de réserver la discussion
pour le projet de loi de finance
d'accord ok c'est le but de votre
amendement madame lavard votre avis sur
les C2 amendements alors ces deux
amendements comme vous l'avez dit sont
presque identiques mais je pense qu'ils
ne rejoignent pas du tout la même
philosophie monsieur gay et Louis
souhaite que l'argent investi sur ce
dispositif à s'asseoirie soit fiscalisé
et pour le gouvernement je suis étonné
de leur amendement parce que je vais
vous citer monsieur le ministre dans la
discussion générale c'était il y a pas
si longtemps vous avez dit explicitement
le plan avenir climat aura un régime
fiscal très incitatif et tout à fait
exceptionnel zéro charge 0 impôts donc
ne nous faites pas croire que vous
attendez encore un arbitrage
interministériel à l'occasion du PLF
pour défiscaliser le dispositif donc
nous on partage et c'est le sens de la
commission des finances que le
dispositif soit présenté dans son
intégralité à savoir l'objet et les
coûts qui sont associés même si je suis
d'accord avec vous les coûts ils sont
pas pour demain pour après-demain ils
seront ils apparaîtront donc dans 18 ans
ou un peu moins que des plans auront été
souscrits et liquides mais pour autant
pour une information complète du
Parlement il est utile d'avoir le
dispositif complet et c'est pour ça que
en commission nous avons introduit la
défiscalisation sur laquelle vous avez
déjà largement communiqué Monsieur Ma
parole d'autant que nous sollicitons
votre avis sur le 278 donc ça va ça
tombe bien
donc avis défavorable sur l'amendement
de Monsieur gay je confirme bon pour mot
ce que j'ai dit devant la représentation
nationale il vaut mieux
l'objectif est que ce produit d'épargne
est 0 impôts et zéro charge à la sortie
c'est la condition de son succès soyons
clairs s'il y a des livrets A qui sont
totalement défiscalisés des socialisés
pour les jeunes de moins de 18 ans que
vous mettez en face un produit vert qui
lui est fiscalisé au socialisé change de
succès nul donc il doit être défiscalisé
et désocialiser nous y tenons beaucoup
sinon cette mobilisation de l'épargne
des jeunes pour le climat ne marchera
pas pour autant nous souhaitons que ce
dispositif fiscal soit dans le PLF par
respect de l'inscription des
dispositions fiscales dans la loi de
finances c'est la seule raison pour
laquelle nous proposons cette amendement
pour répondre à la rapporteur nous
sommes totalement transparents sur ce
que nous souhaitons
pour explication de vote en fait
franchement la présence de cet article
dans la loi sur l'industrie verte n'a
rien d'une évidence absolue et je
comprends le ministre et même je le
remercie de souhaiter qu'il y ait la
transparence complète en inscrivant ça
au PLF mais dans ce cas-là pourquoi ne
pas repousser la création de cette outil
financier au PLF on serait pour le coup
dans un débat qui aurait une cohérence
complète et je ne crois pas que ça a
amputerait le débat sur la nécessité de
réindustrialiser et de façon plus
écologiquement soutenable et responsable
notre pays
merci Monsieur gay
merci madame la Présidente donc le coup
du dispositif
10 à 17 millions qui vont échapper
encore au finances publiques c'est ça et
j'ai une question à vous poser parce
qu'on parle de mobiliser l'épargne des
jeunes c'est quel jeune exactement
commise toute la jeunesse
c'est juste une question parce que le
coup c'est 10 à 17 millions qui vont
échapper au finances publiques je
voulais savoir à quel type de jeunesse
ça va s'adresser
bien on va passer
oui monsieur le ministre vous êtes
[Musique]
juste insister à la prison sur le fait
que ce que nous faisons est archi
classique la création du produit et la
fiscalité du produit l'un ressort d'une
proposition d'un projet de loi c'est ce
que nous vous proposons avec ce produit
et la fiscalité ressortit toujours d'une
loi de finances voilà c'est nous faisons
quelque chose qui est tout ce qui est de
plus classique quant à ce produit
d'épargne je pense que la rapporteur la
très bien décrit il est ouvert à tous
les jeunes
il est ouvert à tous les jeunes nous
verrons ensuite à qui le bénéficiera
mais il peut être plus avantageux qu'un
livret A la garantie n'est pas à 100%
livret
très bien alors je vais donc mettre voix
je suis easy de demande de ce qu'on a
publique sur ses amendements sur le 278
est-ce qu'on peut considérer c'est un
même vote que sur les précédents
voilà
donc le 218 est rejeté
et en revanche le 325 étant un
amendement du Gouvernement je vais le
procéder au scrutin public
qui va être
alors là c'est un scrutin public
monsieur les huissiers
peut-être ouvert
j'ai dit que ce que tu es ouvert alors
j'ai dit que c'était un moment du
gouvernement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission
exprimé 249 pour 41 contre 208 le Sénat
n'a pas adopté je me vois l'article 16
qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté après l'article 16 un amendement
10 de Monsieur brouiller
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres je l'évoquais tout à l'heure
nous souhaitons par cet amendement
répondre à l'objectif qui est affiché
par le gouvernement de mobiliser
l'épargne au profit de la transition
écologique en proposant de réformer les
modalités de gestion des encours du
livret de développement durable et
solidaire qui porte certes dans son nom
durable et solidaire mais dont les
encours ne sont pas une garantie sur ces
deux adjectifs nous proposons donc pour
cela d'augmenter progressivement la
fraction minimale des encours du ldds au
profit du financement de la transition
écologique et de l'économie sociale et
solidaire selon le rythme suivant passer
pour la transition
de 10% à 55% dans les trois ans qui
viennent et pour l'économie sociale et
solidaire de 5 à 20% ce qui ferait
passer la part PME qui était la part
principale de 80
à 40 puis 20%, je rappelle que l'appart
transition n'implique pas du tout de ne
pas être assumé dans des encours de PME
vous avez un amendement identique
bon vous nous avez dit donc
ce nouveau plan d'épargne pour le climat
va s'adresser à tous les jeunes
je pense qu'il nous faudra faire un
point d'étape sur ces questions
parce que je pense moi qui même si
évidemment il est ouvert à toute la
jeunesse
c'est celle et ceux qui ont les moyens
ou surtout les parents auront les moyens
d'abonner le plan d'épargne pour le
climat parce que c'est ça la réalité
si vous arrivez à bien mobiliser les
recettes espérées c'est 1,14 milliards
d'euros le llds c'est 6,26 milliards par
an et déjà un encours qui dépasse les
134 milliards donc nous aussi nous
sommes pour mobiliser cette épargne
d'autant plus que il a été dévoilé au
moment de la prise des mesures
réglementaires si bien que seul 10% du
fond abonde la transition écologique
aujourd'hui et 5% des entreprises de
l'économie sociale et solidaire je vous
remercie
c'est un avis défavorable et peut-être
qu'au regard des arguments que je vais
exposer les auteurs vont retirer leur
amendement qui a quelques effets un peu
horrible entre guillemets je pense qu'il
ne cherche pas à
poursuivre alors notamment en fait si on
suivait la logique des développer dans
ses amendements on aurait un produit le
ldds qui deviendrait plus risqué à
garantir pour l'État ça peut-être que
vous y êtes peu sensible mais surtout
si on venait changer le taux de
centralisation qui deviendrait à 65%
et l'encours du ldds enfin tout ça
aboutirait en fait grosso modo à
soustraire d'un seul coup 95 milliards
d'euros au financement du logement
social
voilà je sens proposition de
compensation donc je ne suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui le secteur du logement
social se porte aussi bien qu'il faille
lui retirer 95 milliards d'euros de
financement enfin le rythme de
réorientation de la partie décentralisée
du ldds et trop rapide par rapport à
l'offre de projets finançables dans la
trajectoire que vous proposez
donc ce qui pourrait avoir des effets
négatifs et j'en rajoute encore sur les
effets un peu problématique c'est que
notamment là on aurait en fait deux
niveaux de normes entre le livret A d'un
côté dont les critères d'allocations et
de répartition serait précisées par
arrêté alors que pour le ldds on aurait
des choses fixées en dur dans la loi
donc finalement deux produits assez
équivalents en termes de gestion du
point de vue de l'épargnant mais dans
les faits significativement différent
puisque l'un serait dû ressort de la loi
alors que l'autre resterait du ressort
de l'arrêté mais je pense que l'argument
du logement social doit vous avoir
convaincu
monsieur le ministre merci ma présidente
j'entends que le ldds a des défauts vous
le dites au fond il est pas très
développement durable et pas très
solidaire essentiellement parce qu'il
est par la loi dans un capital garanti
donc il permet la rapporter la maladie
de financer des activités sociales
notamment le logement social mais son
investissement c'est du monétaire et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on crée le
plan épargne à venir climat pour avoir
un plan
d'épargne exposé au climat plus risqué
certes mais avec un rendement plus
favorable qui ça ouvrir à tous et à
toutes je tiens à préciser quand même
que le ministre a demandé de réunir le
comité de financement de la transition
écologique
présidé par Bruno Le Maire Christophe
Béchu mais aussi espérier qui est une
personnalité qualifiée le 12 juillet
prochain pour demander aux banques de
verdir l'emploi des fonds des ldds mais
votez pour le plan épargne avec climat
c'est la meilleure manière de financer
le climat pour toutes et toutes les
épargnants de moins de 18 ans
merci
même votre que pour des amendements
précédents auprès déposés par les mêmes
auteurs ils sont donc rejetés après
l'article 16 monsieur Breuillet le 13
cet amendement vise d'une part à rendre
obligatoire la communication du niveau
d'implication des fonds commercialisés
dans des activités polluantes et d'autre
part à rendre visible la liste des
principaux secteurs et entreprises dans
lesquels les font investissent il s'agit
d'un enjeu important pour la finance
verte en améliorant la transparence de
l'ensemble des produits d'épargne afin
d'inciter les Françaises et les Français
à orienter leur épargne hors des
activités contraires aux objectifs
climatiques le principe est simple avec
une notation des fonds en trois niveaux
qui s'inspirent d'ailleurs des outils
d'information au consommateurs
développés dans l'alimentation le
logement ou l'électroménager bleu un
fond qui n'a pas d'exposition à des
entreprises dans les énergies fossiles
jaunes des entreprises impliquées dans
les énergies fossiles mais en cours de
transition et rouge une exposition à des
entreprises polluantes et son plan de
transition je vous propose donc de
mettre en place une telle notation qui
éclairera utilement
et fera facilitera la liberté de choix
des investisseurs et des particuliers
dans les dans les projets
d'investissement vert
merci quelle est la vie de la Commission
sur cet amendement
alors si tu en avis défavorable même si
je trouve l'idée assez intéressante
parce que notamment elle rend beaucoup
plus accessible la